I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about the Nagaywaza. So I
made a Nagaywaza overview. I've been
talking about Nagwaza different lately
and I think it's a good way to talk
about it. So I'm going to give you uh
the new way I kind of talk about it and
uh then I'm going to make some videos
specifically talking about each of the
seven orthodox Nagaywaza and um uh how
those play out with this system that I'm
going to give you for talking about the
Nagaywaza. So, uh, that's it. I'm g call
Josh over to work. Josh.
All right. So, let's talk about the
Nagaywaza. I've already given you guys a
Nagaywaza overview and talked basically
about how I think about the Nagaywaza.
And I think there are seven orthodox
Nagwaza. So, Kokyag, Kaitenag, Koshi
Nag, Kagash, Idimag, Shihonag, and
Jujinag. So, those are not, of course,
all the throws that exist in Aikido.
There's tons of other throws, right?
Teninag is a good example. A lot of
styles have teninagumoto
tosh, mayotosh, iikyotosh, tons of other
throws that you see in iikido styles,
but those seven, you're kind of
hardressed to not find some variation of
those. And they might use a different
name, but the way those throws play out,
they exist kind of in all iikido styles.
So, uh, once I kind of figured that out,
I just I geared all of my training
basically towards those seven and and
those are the main throws we learn in
the school. And you know about a year a
little more than a year or so back about
the time actually that I was working on
the um the the Nagaywaza overview I was
kind of thinking about why why why are
those you know and and the thoughts have
kind of come through my head at
different times and and now I just kind
of have a different way to talk about it
and uh I'm just just kind of just
working into this new way talking about
and I think it makes a lot of sense. So
let's look at our basic positions that
we have right. So we have muhani and
that's without hanmi and I'm square to
Josh and in iikido situation this is the
worst position and the reason for that
simple Josh is going to be stronger and
better than me so he's going to beat me
in this position. So I always want some
kind of positional advantage. So the
first thing that's not terrible in
iikido is a hanmi right? Okay. And so
from hani we have gaku hani and ihani
depending on how I'm aligned to him.
Right. Okay. Then an improved position
from that's hitoi side by side and
there's you know several ways to do
hitoi but we're side by side and then
edi the best position I'm behind him.
Okay. Now, when we're looking at our
nagwaza, what is it we're trying to do?
So, in nagwaza, we are trying to move
someone away from us. That's what nag
means to project away. And because of
the way we think about martial arts, we
tend to think that throwing naga has to
do with throwing something on the
ground, right? But that's kind of weird
because in English, if I say throw
something, no one throws it like that,
right? Everyone almost always throws it
out. Okay? So projecting something out
is another way to do nagwaza. And I've
talked about this before, but I think
it's important to understand when I'm
doing nagwaza, I just want someone away
from me. That's the whole purpose of
nagwaza. So if we ask why might I need
to do nagwaza? Well, it's because other
stuff's not working out for me and
they're close to me. Now, they're going
to be close to me in one of those
positions we just talked about, right?
Okay. For the purpose of the naggi was
in the way I'm going to talk about it
right now. We're going to look at muhani
and hanmi about in the same situation
and they're really not very good because
I'm still on this frontal plane of Josh
where Josh has got a lot of power. So
yes, it's a little better for me here
and I I need to at least be in this
position to be doing some kind of iikido
stuff. It's always the first place I'm
getting but it's not hugely better for
me. This is significantly better. Right.
So Josh is much more weakened in the
state. Um, and then this of course is
way better. In iikido, we're working
throws from the most common position,
which I believe in Iikido is going to be
in just turn he side by side. Okay? And
it's because this is what we're likely
to get into when we're doing stuff. If
you wrestle around with weapons, you'll
find yourself in this position all the
time, right? If you're doing rondor,
you're going to find yourself in this
position all the time. So, this is where
the majority of our throws come from.
And we have fewer throws back here and
fewer throws up here. Okay, so I know I
know I'm taking a long time to get here,
but um I I'm setting this up so you guys
can can follow along. There are only two
major iikido throws that happen from
this frontal position. Okay, those
throws are koshi nag and kitanag. Those
are the major throws that happen from
here. If Josh is overwhelming me on this
line, right? So he's overwhelming me on
this line. I have basically two options.
One, he's overwhelming me like this
where he's high and I go low and this
sets up our koshi nag, right? Okay. Or
he's overwhelming me and he's going low
and that's our kitanag. Okay. So that's
why we have two throws from the front
position. I can't get out of the front
position. And Josh is either going to be
a high Josh or a low Josh. If he's a
high Josh, I go low. That gives me
advantage. He falls over me. That's
koshiag. or Josh is going to try to get
under me and I do kitanag by turning and
that gives us kiteanag. So there's only
two throws that happen from here. Now
when we're investigating forearms and
trying to understand how stuff works,
this a lot of times confuses us and
makes us go to a bad position. So for
example, if we were doing katate dori
koshinag, in order to do katori koshag,
I have to go to a worse position than I
was in and then do my throw. Okay. The
problem with that is we don't we we
think that the throw for some reason is
more important than the position we're
in. And that's not true because actually
what's happening is I'm not going here.
Josh is coming here to get me. And as he
comes here to get me, I let him come to
get me. And that gives me a koshiaki.
Sorry, Violet. And you weren't prepared
for that. But um so I was watching. So
Oh, my mic packed. That was that was
sweet of you. Um anyway, so so the koshi
nag comes from him coming around to get
me better, right? So that's what he's
looking for is to come around and get me
better. So that's why I have to do
koshag. Okay, we could also be at an
inside position like this and Josh tries
to get under my arm and then that's what
sets up our kiteag. So the frontal
position has koshag and kitanag. So if
you start to understand that's like well
if I'm stuck in that position the way I
project someone away is either I go low
and they go over the top or they go low
and I go on top and and do kitanag but
turning. Okay now the sidebyside
position there's a ton of things that
are going to happen from this. Now we
will again get kitanag. So if Josh came
low from this position I do kiteanag
right? So that works just the same from
hitoi. It's our basic technique for low
stuff. However we're going to get a lot
of other throws from here as well.
Kokunag is our main throw from here.
This throw coming through like this,
right? Where I'm shearing his hips in
half. Okay. Now, that can be done this
way. And this is going to look tricky
because it's gonna look like an edi for
a second. And I believe a version of
Edidy Minag does this, but I could also
do it like this, right? So either way,
where I'm facing same side as him or
opposite him. By throwing my hips
through his, I start to knock him away
from me. Right now, understand, I don't
care if he falls. If he just stumbles
away when I do this, I got the distance
I want. Right? So that's very valuable
to me. So, our main throw from Hitoi is
going to be kokunag. That's going to be
an important throw. Okay. But what if he
had something in his hand and I had to
check it or I had something in my hand
and he wants to check it, right? Then
we're going to get a lot of other
throws. So, for example, let's say he
was holding this hand. So, we went to
gaku, right? Maybe I came over here,
bang, and I tried to get him off with a
royo or something. It doesn't work. If I
switched and put the knife in this hand
and come here, we're going to get all
juji stuff, right? Same situation. If I
had his hand here and I'm going to do
Rokio and he comes to attack me high
with that other hand, then we're going
to go here and we're going to get Juji
again. So Juji is the throw we're going
to go to from Hito and me. If we're
striking and holding a hand, right?
That's the throw that's going to happen.
That's jujag. Our arms become entangled.
Now, what if I'm isolating a hand? Okay.
So, I could be isolating a hand like
this and we're going to get kaggishas
from that, right? So, so meaning I need
to get this guy away from me, but I got
to hold this hand when I do it. I'm
going to tear at it this way and that's
going to give me a projection. and he's
going to stumble away from me that way
while I'm checking for this hand, right?
Same would be true if he had my hand in
some kind of configuration, right? And I
came up here like this and I get a I get
a kodish, right? So, we're isolating a
hand. And the same is true for shihonag
if we're isolating a hand and continuing
soot to the backside. So, if I'm
isolating his hand here and I want to
turn to the backside, we get a shihonag
for it. And if he was holding me,
exactly the same thing. And I turn to
the backside and we get a koshag for or
sorry shyonag for it. Right? So shionag
are going to appear because we're
isolating a hand. Kagashas are going to
appear because we're isolating a hand.
Jujinag are going to appear because
we're we're holding one hand and
attacking with the other hand. Kokunag
are going to happen simply because we're
in side by side position. Hitoi and
kaunag are going to happen because he
goes low from here. Right? So now we
understand all those throws that happen
and why they would happen and where they
come from. So this position should
immediately start alerting you to these
things are going to become available.
The last set we have in that is edi. So
eddy minag are throws that happen when I
get here behind. Okay. Now the classic
edi that we talk about always looks kind
of like this. I pull him down. I'm
watching my mic here. Uh I come across
the top and I step through and that's
the one we see a lot. Now that can
happen for one of a few reasons, right?
One is I just do what I think the most
basic edidim minag is which is to pull
him down from here like this. Okay.
Another could be Josh is turning and I
lock his head in place and he throws
himself off balance because his head
can't turn as his body turns. Okay. And
the other one is a kokunag really I
believe which is I'm moving his hips out
of the way as I'm in that position.
Right. So those three are all apparent
in that one version of edimag but really
any throw that happens from the edimi
position. Now we only have one throw
done a few different ways. But the
reason for that is I'm in the dominant
position most of the time. I don't need
to worry about knocking him away from
me. And the main edidimi nag we see is
an edimag that keeps him from turning
and taking away my edimi position.
Right? So, and that's the one where I
lock his head in place and we
classically see a lot. So, if you use
this kind of positional ranking system
to start understanding the throws, it
will be more apparent when the throws
come out. Right? So, so this is a new
way I'm working on talking about. I'm
actually going to make a set of videos
for you guys on each one of these throws
individually from this positional
situation stuff. And so you'll be seeing
them over the next seven weeks, I guess.
Um, so I'm going to make a series of
those for you and talking about how
those throws really play out and what I
think about those throws and all that
stuff. But this is the overview for how
I'm now talking positionally about the
Nagaywaza. I'm Christopher Hines, Joshua
Tihi, my Salano McDaniels behind the
center camera right there. And we'll see
you in the next video.